gare de Lyon
[Musique]
ah mon Dieu ça me dégoûte même à
l'étranger chacun y va de son petit
commentaire dans la presse on voit que
ça étaler jusqu'aux États-Unis le
magazine Forbes qui dit que Paris n'est
plus si romantique il en est question
aussi évidemment beaucoup en Europe chez
nos voisins et ceux qui se montrent
particulièrement critiques ce sont les
Espagnols vous voyez le beau Paris un
fumier des saints de pendus ou slogan
hostile à la réforme des retraites le
local du député Renaissance Guillaume
gouffiercha a été vandalisé la nuit
dernière avant scène depuis jeudi elle
utilisation par la première ministre
Elisabeth borne de l'article 49-3 au
moins lui permanences de parlementaires
de la majorité ont été saccagés sur
l'ensemble du territoire
et Paris sommeil est en colère on le
sait si l'exécutif a choisi le 49-3
c'est parce que le vote à l'assemblée
était trop incertain la première
ministre a eu cette phrase
habituellement réservée à un zoophile
devant un hamster ça risque d'être trop
serré
alors
ça n'est pas un échec puisque il y a un
texte et ce texte sera si la notion de
censure est rejetée mise en oeuvre vous
rendez compte là la folie de ces gens
c'est pas un échec mais je le répète
c'est tellement incroyable en fait
comment alors évidemment faut condamner
toute violence mais comment voulez-vous
que les gens d'abord ne se
désintéressent pas de ces gens-là
n'aille plus après
ou ail plus exactement voté quand ils
entendent ça mais on les prend pour des
cons en fait ils en peuvent plus ils ont
déjà les corps usés et vous vous allez
leur dire vous allez au culot madame de
leur dire qu'il faut qu'il travaille
jusqu'à 64 ans mais vous êtes insolent
parce que vous êtes violentes comme
Monsieur Macron et mon appel et je lance
son album solennellement ce soir j'en ai
pour 30 secondes c'est d'appeler tous
les Français toutes les Françaises à
descendre devant leur préfecture devant
leur mairie ce soir même place de la
Concorde en face de l'Assemblée
nationale la façade est éventrée la
permanence d'ericciotti a été caillassie
hier soir
sur le mur cette menace la motion ou le
pavé à la veille de l'examen des deux
motions de censure à l'Assemblée les
manifestants mettent la pression sur
leurs députés quitte à camper encore et
encore devant ces permanences
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de pouvoir la fantasmer ou de pouvoir la
jouer un peu comme vous voulez mais on
est de toute façon oui je suis je suis
aussi je suis citoyen parce que face à
des politiciens qui nous mettent à
genoux qui se foutent de vos gueules aux
gens qui sont autour du plateau là qui
se fout de nos vies qui ont plus
d'intérêt pour l'argent que pour la vie
des gens et bien il faut se bouger il
faut se faire entendre faut se révolter
faut plus accepter de se faire marcher
dessus il faut être debout il faut
s'inscrire dans l'héritage des
révolutionnaires des communards des
maquisards de toutes celles et la
violence
plus les citoyens
il faut savoir
que vous êtes euh des concentré de
pétards
selon ce journal italien Emmanuel Macron
aurait défié l'Assemblée et le peuple en
Allemagne le Franck fourter
la méthode Macron a échoué et cette
correspondante permanente à Paris de la
chaîne a r d il voit une victoire pour
Marine Le Pen sous homme une chose est
claire ce soir Marine Le Pen veut
prendre les commandes et en profiter
une crise politique qui a pour effet
immédiat la chute de popularité du
président de la République qui passe
sous la barre des 30% dans le baromètre
ifope du Journal du dimanche il faut
remonter à la crise des gilets jaunes il
y a 4 ans pour trouver des niveaux
d'impopularité comparable
idem pour la première ministre Elisabeth
borne qui se maintient à son plus bas
niveau de popularité depuis son arrivée
à Matignon et qui devra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vois ce qui se passe j'ai des choses
qui m'agacent quand je vois les
assemblées je me dis que il y a quand
même des gens très intelligents tout
bord confondu comment ça se fait qu'en
fait il y en ait aucun qui ne s'écoute
chacun prêche pour sa paroisse ça me
paraît fou je me dis essayer de vous
entendre on est là on vous regarde
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
[Musique]
à 74 et pour les survivants ce qui
restent au doute tellement bien le coup
ne laissons pas échapper ses sous
le microscope
je peux prendre le micro s'il te plaît
mais je merci
une fois de plus voilà va t'acheter un
blouson mon chéri
non il avait un beau blouson nubuck ça
en compagnon rien que pour ça il a bien
fait de venir